hello everyone and welcome
to today's live broadcast the evolving
role of microbiology lab covid 19
ams and new automated technologies that
improve
rapid diagnostics i'm cece valdez of
labyrinths and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you
by lab roots and sponsored by bd
for more information about our sponsor
please visit their site
at bd.com so let's get started i want to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click
on the send button also if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd now like to introduce our presenters
first joining us
dr james snyder professor of pathology
and laboratory medicine from university
of louisville
and medical director of the clinical bio
microbiology and molecular diagnostics
laboratory at the university of
louisville
hospital also joining us dr romney
humphries
professor in pathology and technology
at vanderbilt university medical center
and medical director of
microbiology at vanderbilt university
medical center
for a complete biography on our
presenter please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen
dr humphries you may now begin your
presentation
well thank you so much and thank you all
for joining us today
so i'll be talking a little bit about
antimicrobial resistance
and some of the challenges that we've
all faced in the clinical microbiology
lab
with regards to resistance during the
kobit 19 pandemic
here are my disclosures
and i'm going to start out with a case
so this case was from when i first
started at vanderbilt
in august where we had a 65 year old man
who was diagnosed with covid19 at an
outside hospital
he was intubated had high ventilation
settings
deep sedation and paralysis a very
complicated course for covid19
he received many different therapies
including dexamethasone rem deservier
vancomycin and pipercilantazebactam for
presumed bacterial co-infections
and ultimately he was transferred to v
umc at his family's request
when he came to us he was septic and he
had a lot of
sputum being produced with deep inline
suctioning through his vent
and so you can see here his chest x-ray
where you can see a lot of consolidation
in the right lung
as well as um what we grew out of this
with heavy growth of acetobacter
balmonii
so you know very classic for ventilator
associated pneumonia one of the risks
that we
see with patients that are on
ventilators for prolonged periods of
time
so when we did susceptibility testing
for this organism unfortunately as you
can see
on the left this was a very resistant
acetobacter balmanii
and so you can see based on the mic's
here with our antimicrobials
the mic shown and it was resistant to
every agent
tested so the clinical team
uh called the lab and said you know this
is a pretty difficult case for us
do you have any thoughts on other
antimicrobial agents
that might have activity against
multi-drug resistant acetobacter bombani
and this is a question that comes up um
you know every now and then
certainly it's sporadically during the
pandemic but even outside of the
pandemic
where we're seeing these increasingly
multi-drug resistant gram-negative
bacteria
and so when we look at our options as
far as
newer antimicrobial agents
many different things came up so the
first was septazine
av bactam this is a newer antimicrobial
with
activities specifically against
carbopenamase producers
but when we look at this newer
antimicrobial the activity against
multi-drug resistant acetobacters is
actually pretty limited
the reason for this is it's not true
carbopenomes production that's the main
consideration for mdr acetobacter
bowmanii
um and our isolate itself had an mic of
greater than 16. and this was a test
that was done
um on our bd phoenix mic panels
just as part of our routine testing um
another option that was floated was
septualizing tazobactam
but this agent really did not have
activity against multi-drug resistant
aspirative actor
and sure enough you can see for our
isolate the mic was greater than 32.
a newer agent that has come to market is
impenetractam
again very limited activity in these
cases a multi-drug-resistant acne
bacter with an mic in our particular
isolate of greater than 16.
ameripen and vaporbactam is really a kpc
drug
and again no activity against mdrs need
native actor
and the other thing that came up and
often we hear a discussion about it is
tigercycling
and tigercycling does not have clinical
breakpoints for
acetobacter bombania in fact most of
these agents i've mentioned just now
do not um and really mics are in the
four microgram per ml range typically
for these organisms
and again not a great agent for us
native actor
and so what we're left with are two
newer agents the federal call
which is a citroforocephalosporin
and in this case the mic was 0.5 and
plasma myosin which is a newer
aminoglycoside that does have activity
against mdr acnetobacter
and testing for this particular agent
can be quite challenging we actually
were unable to get
our isolate tested for plasomycin
and so you know the bottom line here
just to comment on
these multi-drug resistant acne bacters
can be very difficult to treat and
despite a lot of really good
antimicrobial development
in the last five to ten years that
target these multi-drug resistant gram
negatives acidobacter balmania
unfortunately is an organism that's been
left a little bit behind
with very few agents that actually have
good activity
so here's another case this one is a
much more
recent case and this was in february of
this year
this is a 56 year old man with diabetes
crohn's and asthma who's on some
immunosuppressants
in early january he was diagnosed with
covid19
unfortunately his diagnosis took a
little bit longer
because this individual actually refused
testing
um for coppit19 up until the point
pretty much when he was admitted to
hospital
again he received a variety of different
therapeutic options
you can see his ct scan here where his
lungs are in
very rough shape they intubated him in
mid-january
sent him over to us and he's had many
infectious complications associated with
his covet 19
including candidate labrada in his
blood as well as just like our past
patient
ventilator-associated pneumonia due to a
carbopenem-resistant anaerobic or cloacy
in this case
so here are that individual patient
susceptibility results and so
what you can see here is um we
performed on our phoenix the cpo detect
test which said it was a class a beta
lactamase this
test provides information on the
presence of beta-lactamases and
their classes if they're carbopenomases
for the enterics
we confirmed this with the pcr which
sure enough showed the presence of kpc
and very typical for kpc producers um it
was resistant to the majority of agents
that we tested with the exception of
septazidine av bactim and annie casen
and so in this case we treated this
patient with septazidine av
bactam
unfortunately for this patient two weeks
after he was treated with this drug his
isolate recurred
and it was now resistant to ceftasidine
av bacterium
and interestingly the mic for maripenum
was now in the susceptible range
we confirmed the presence of kpc still
in this isolate
and what we found through doing a little
bit of
additional work was that this particular
isolate had mutated
the kpc gene um in the region called the
omega loop which is where adibactam
binds
which leads to resistance to cephtazine
av
bactam but susceptibility to the
carbopenems
thankfully in these cases meropenem
vaporbactem retains activity
and this is what our patient was treated
with
so these two cases i think highlight
some of the things that we were very
concerned about
at the onset of the pandemic with
regards to antimicrobial resistance
and there is a fair amount of concern
surrounding the management of patients
with cobit 19 and
the continued and maybe even accelerated
emergence
of resistance what we do know
is about 71 70 of patients
receive antibiotics with a covid19
diagnosis particularly those that are
hospitalized
only four percent of them actually have
a true bacterial infection and so there
is a pretty
big disconnect and the reason that these
patients are receiving antibiotics
is simply because of an excess of
caution these individuals are quite ill
and we want to make sure that we're
treating them to the best of our ability
and about 15 of hospitalized patients
will develop a secondary bacterial
infection like the two cases i just
described
and so you know the reasons for this use
of antimicrobial
include some issues with medical
misinformation particularly outside the
united states there's been a huge
emphasis
on the use of antibiotics such as
epithermicin
to prevent or even treat covid19
if you go to some countries like india
as an example
this is touted as a way to prevent
infection with covid19 and
you can go to your local pharmacy and
receive a zithromycin over the counter
in those countries
and what we do see is that there is some
evidence that because of these factors
resistance is increasing and one study
showed
about a 10 increase in their
antimicrobial resistance rates
at their single institution when they
compared
the pre-covered 19 isolates to the post
coven 19 pandemic isolates
what's really interesting about the
present pandemic is unlike other
viral pandemics where community acquired
pneumonia was a major cause
of morbidity and mortality secondary to
influenza
as an example we don't see that as much
with coven 19.
and so if you take a look at some of the
you know compare and contrast
information
like i mentioned community acquired
pneumonia was pretty prevalent in the
2009 influenza pandemic
and this was caused by nasopharyngeal
colonizing bacteria
that then led to secondary infections
and so quite frequently you would see
pneumonia caused by staph aureus
pneumococcus or group a strap
all of these are colonizers that can
then lead to
a community acquired type pneumonia in
contrast in copin 19 what we're seeing
just like our two
cases is more instances of hospital or
ventilator acquired pneumonia
and these are hospital pathogens that
are causing these secondary infections
the good news is that the incidence of
this is significantly lower than what we
would maybe see in other pandemics
but the organisms are more difficult to
treat so we're seeing gram-negative
bacteria a fair amount of staph aureus
as well as some secondary infections
caused by
fungal pathogens
so when we talk take a little step back
and think about the ways we can mitigate
this increased
incidence of antimicrobial resistance i
mean the first thing of course is to
continue support the activities of
antibiotic stewardship
programs in the early days of the
pandemic i don't know how many
stewardship physicians i talked to who
said you know we've pretty much thrown
stewardship out the window while we're
trying to just
manage the sheer scope of this pandemic
but we're seeing a significant return to
those good stewardship
principles that we follow in routine
times
we also interestingly throughout the
pandemic have seen fewer outpatient
physician visits and so in countries
where
antimicrobials require a prescription
you actually
have seen reduced use of antimicrobials
in the outpatient domain
we're also seeing increased emphasis on
hand hygiene
masking and social distancing and so all
of these things help cut back
the number of outpatient and even
hospital associated infections
and we want to of course continue the
appropriate use of diagnostic testing
and so what we have seen in our own
institution is many patients with copin
19 never get a sputum culture done
and maybe this is because of the concern
of collecting a sputum specimen for
culture and so they're being treated
empirically
rather than based on the lab based
data and so this is an instance where
increased diagnosis may in fact be
helpful conversely we went through a
period where we were rejecting almost
all of the sputum that came
from patients on covid 19 floors
and this was due to very poor specimen
quality and so again there's not a lot
of value
in culturing saliva even if the patient
has covid19 just like if there's not a
lot of value to culturing that saliva if
they don't
and so you know following these good lab
practices is really critical as we're
you know making our way hopefully
through the end part of this pandemic
and so what can we do here in the lab
well i think that it's always important
to um you know be continually reviewing
what we're doing from a susceptibility
testing perspective and asking the
question is this sufficient for our
population
and so by that i mean are we testing
newer drugs that maybe are needed
if we're seeing a higher incidence of
resistance
and are those newer drugs addressing the
pathogens that we're seeing so in the
first
example um if you're at an institution
that's seeing a lot of multi-drug
resistant acetobacter
having the ability to either send out
with some
level of ease or do in-house the federal
call testing might be an
option that could really help your
patients
conversely if you're seeing a lot of
carbapenemas producers
having the ability to test those
carbopytamines producing
of antimicrobials that act specifically
against those carbopytamises
is a value and like i showed in the
second case susceptibility can never be
just
assumed by the presence of a given
antimicrobial
resistance determinant like kvc the
other thing we want to do is make sure
that we're staying up to date with break
points
and this is a really big concern we
shared some data
in an aphl webinar earlier this year
that showed less than half of labs in
the united states are up to date with
even
break points that were set in 2010 so
these are breakpoints now that are more
than a decade out of date
and so you want to make sure that you're
staying up to date with those
breakpoints so the testing that you're
doing in your lab is being interpreted
by the right standards and finally and
this is super important and
i talk about this all the time in my own
lab is we want to be constantly vigilant
in reviewing our susceptibility test
results if something's not making sense
if there's unusual resistance or unusual
susceptibility that's something that
needs to be investigated further before
that patient report is put out
all right so let's move to another case
this one was from september
um in 2020 um this is a four
day old baby girl her mom had very
limited prenatal care throughout the
pandemic
and she was brought in by ambulance to
our facility because
mom noticed that she quit breathing and
so when she came in
she was found to have bilateral purulent
conjunctivitis with some conjunctival
lesions
her x-ray which is a little bit
difficult to see i know because it's so
tiny that
um showed interstitial fluid um in both
lungs
and so they started her on ampicillin
and gender myosin and when infectious
diseases was consulted they added on
cephatoxine
her sputum cultures in our eye cultures
grew neisseria gonorrhea
and sure enough it turned out that mom
was positive for niceria gonorrhea as
well
this is the second case that we actually
saw just this month
of a 36 year old man with bilateral knee
pain
and rash he was septic when he came into
the emergency department and his blood
cultures grew gram-negative diplococci
um which are shown on the gram stain
again a little bit tricky to see here
but
you'll have to trust me and this
actually grew out niceria gonorrhea and
so this was a case of disseminated
gonococcal infection
and so these are things that we're
seeing with increasing frequency and i
truly believe that a lot of this has to
do with reduced access to outpatient
healthcare
and so there have been a lot of
challenges with testing
for copin 19 we've all had issues
getting pipette tips or
test reagents or kits or what have you
for cobit 19.
but testing outside of the actual
pandemic has also been very challenging
due to supply limitations and so some
data from the american society for
microbiology that's been trying to track
this showed in january 35
of labs were experiencing shortages of
supplies for testing of sexually
transmitted diseases
like our gonococcal cases you know what
really compounded this problem is that
the culture media for recovering
organisms like niceria gonorrhea was
also unavailable
and then to even make it more
challenging is that at that time there
were national shortages for key drugs
for the treatment of these sexually
transmitted diseases
such as azithromycin penicillin g and
actually the erythromycin
ophthalmolic ointment that is given to
babies when they're born
to prevent gonococcal conjunctivitis and
so
all of these things really led to the
types of cases that i just described in
the previous slide
you know it's not just sexually
transmitted infections that are impacted
but we're seeing shortages across the
board
for a variety of different testing
supplies you can see here for bacterial
cultures
mycology cultures uh mycobacteria
parasites as well all of these being
challenging and it really as i'm sure
those of you in the lab
appreciate fluctuate day-to-day very
challenging to deal with um it feels
like there's a new issue
every day like i mentioned
you know i believe that we're seeing
some of these more disseminated cases
i've never seen this many in my career
due to reduced access to
outpatient care and this has been noted
in other countries in italy
the italian group has done a nice job of
publishing on this
where they've seen a decrease in the
number of
non-acute cases so these are you know
more mild cases of chlamydia gonorrhea
or syphilis
but an increase in the number of acute
cases
and they really felt that again that
this was due to patients who aren't
seeking
care when they suspected sexually
transmitted infections simply due to the
restrictions
imposed by the pandemic
so like i mentioned we've dealt with a
lot of testing shortages and this has
also
impacted susceptibility testing and i've
kind of given a little bit of a list
here to show you what we've dealt with
recently
actually just this morning we're dealing
with a shortage of our test cards
and so you can see it ranged the gamut
from homophilus test media
our rpmi auger that we used for
candidate e-testing
the mueller hint inaugural blood mueller
hintenauger our
susceptibility test system inoculation
broth all these different things
in the supply chain has been very
difficult to manage
and so a lot of us have done um you know
the best we can by swapping out our
media
or discs for alternative uh vendors
and you know in in normal times we
always talk about in normal times in my
life but
outside the pandemic before you went
ahead and swapped out manufacturers of
one of these
you would maybe do a bit more of an
extended verification to really be sure
that you weren't going to see a big
shift in your test results
um in copied times however often we just
don't have the luxury to do that
and so the approach that we've been
taking is more of a risk assessment
type of approach to inform how we deal
with these
swaps and so you know we take a look at
the types of risks for example a risk of
false susceptibility um the likelihood
of that
by switching out for example mueller
hinton augur would be pretty low
the impact could be that the patient
fails therapy and the way we've
addressed this through mitigation
is carefully reviewing our qc carefully
reviewing
our isolate results and evaluating for
any trends that we might see
other types of things that we might see
happen if i jump down
to changes in the mic well you know
subtle changes in our mics might
happen with a higher likelihood and the
impact of the patient could be maybe
if you have a stewardship team that's
really nuancing that mic in the dose
they may be adjusting the dose
incorrectly and this is a lower risk and
so it'd be just important to discuss
mic variability not just in this time
but as a whole
with your pharmacy and clinicians etc
and i do want to just point out there
has been some nice data
done both by clsi and ucas that's looked
at
failure rates for ast media and even so
these are not exempt media the failure
rate is
really low like 0.04 for mueller hinton
and 0.03 for blood meal or hinton
so the types of um things that might
impact the mueller hinton from
manufacturer to manufacturer
that could impact performance include
subtle differences in ph
the aggro depth the content of divalent
cations or thymine
and so you can see here these are some
data from ucas that took a look at a
variety of different media
far more than i'm showing on this slide
but i'm just showing ones that are
available here in the u.s
and they looked at their qc results for
just diffusion
of being within a single millimeter from
that target
and you can see that even across these
different media
the majority of results are really tight
within a millimeter of that midpoint on
the qc range
and if you looked at whether or not they
were inside that qc range it was 95
percent
the drugs they found the most impacted
included trim sulfa aminoglycosides and
fluoroquinolones
and so you know the type of qc that you
need to
do when you're making a change to these
media is outlined in m 100 in the clsi
document
and so you can see here if you're using
a new manufacturer of disk they
recommend to just do a single day of qc
if you're using a new manufacturer of
media they suggest
five days of qc and so you can use this
to point to where you're
making these changes how to do it
um you want to review your qc data and
so this is some example
of where we switched manufacturers and
we went from
weekly qc to daily qc when we switched
the manufacturer
and what you can see here is that our
genomics and qc results for
e coli really didn't change all that
much
but when we looked at our pseudomonas or
reginosa qc stream we did see a shift
upwards in where those qc values were
sitting
and so if you again go to that m100
document
in table 5g there is some data that
tells you what you might notice
if for example you're seeing your
pseudomonas genomics and qc being out
it could be related to the cation
concentration in that media
and and so what you might do then
is take a look at other drugs that might
be
impacted by that calcium and magnesium
content being a little bit off
and just keeping an eye on those
particular drugs as you're going forward
with your testing
so again you know it's not to over
complicate this
but to just provide some general
guidance and some troubleshooting for if
you do start seeing
changes or shifts in your trends
so a couple of thoughts you know that
we've had to go through with our supply
shortages is that we've
had to on a couple of occasions triaged
our testing
and so we've had to come up with plans
for how to deal with for example
shortages for our molecular tests for
blood cultures
and focusing in on patients as a
priority coming from
the immunocompromised words compared to
other words
um you know it's always a good idea to
periodically review your sop
and to see if all the testing that you
do routinely if it's really needed and
so some of the things that we stopped
doing throughout the pandemic and i
think we'll continue
to not do is susceptibility testing of
candida isolates from genital specimens
routinely
haemophilus testing on every single
respiratory specimen
versus only doing it if it's indicated
by that quality score
on the specimen and then testing of
coagulase negative staff
isolated from blood cultures you know
you want to use the media you can get
it's the reality of this pandemic
but keep an eye out for trends and
always try to be as practical as
possible
so to summarize my little bit
antimicrobial resistance remains a
concern
i think sometimes we miss this pandemic
in the middle of the other pandemic
we're going through
and as reduced access to outpatient care
continues we are seeing some interesting
trends like the emergence of sexually
transmitted infections
um or infections further along in the
process
um than you might see patients
presenting with otherwise
and we are all dealing with continued
testing issues and this is likely to
keep going for some time yet and so
hopefully i've given some thoughts
at least for thought on how to approach
these types of challenges
so i want to thank my team at vanderbilt
this is our microbiology team and our
covid testing team they're
an absolutely fantastic group of folks
and
i'm going to pass it over now to dr
snyder who will be talking about
automation
and covid19 dr snyder
thank you very much and it's a pleasure
to
speak with you today and thank you for
your participation as well
and we're going to be speaking for a few
moments on the
total laboratory automation and how does
this relate to
to covet and
by way of disclosures as i've listed
here for you
the objectives uh for this presentation
consist of
primarily three uh share with you a
little bit about our experience and
benefits of the tla
the current keister tla which we've had
in our laboratory
for nearly three years and then the
impact that covet has had
on our planning our staffing and testing
while still trying to maintain
our regular services as listed on the
slide
including bacteriology and
susceptibility testing and others
and then discuss our experience in a
clinical trial
that was performed with a research use
only
automated prototype and i should
acknowledge the fact that we were one of
two laboratories
in the world uh selected to do this
clinical trial the other being in wasan
switzerland
some of you may have seen this in the
journal clinical microbiology but
there's really a little controversy
going on between these two individuals
one is highlighting you know hey we're
really
uh automated tla and
the other individuals kind of looking at
him with some uh
reservations hey what do you mean total
laboratory automation you still have to
do
manual processing of some specimens
gram stains and etc so the question is
is it really total laboratory automation
and hopefully at the end of my
presentation
i think you'll be convinced that total
laboratory
automation has arrived in the clinical
laboratory
so let's start with a little bit about
our impact
of the kova testing i'm sure we're no
different than any of you out there but
we had several challenges that were
initially
approached to manage the situation
such as testing capacity how many could
we do
24 7 how many platforms would we need
for molecular testing we had one at that
particular time
we also as all of you did faced with the
challenge
of weekly allocation of reagents and
kits
which forces you to strategize and to
determine which platform is available
to handle the current volume at that
time
not to mention the swab and the
transport supplies
i would also add into that
bacteriological media
primarily for bacteriology as well as
mycology it was also an issue
that we had to deal with and
at the same time we had the
responsibility of maintaining our
regular operations in the respective
sections
as you see them there and at the same
time be supporting
the covet testing once again 24
7. probably our biggest challenge was
testing personnel
we obviously got into a situation like
once again i don't think we're any
different than many of you out there
where we were testing a huge volume
of covered specimens
coming in throughout the day and night
and so testing personnel
was was a challenge and before the euas
were
uh available uh that question was
posed to the staff and we asked
what are we gonna do if we are going to
be testing covert which you know we are
and based upon that particular
discussion we had decided
we needed to increase primarily
processors
not necessarily medical technologists
but we did bring on three or four
additional processors
who also were trained to load the
keister system
and uh with with the automation provided
by the keystroke these people were
relatively free or had more
freedom to access log in and deliver the
coveted specimens
to the molecular diagnostics laboratory
he also had to deal with who gets tested
first
and that's where we had to enter into
conversations with lab management
chief medical officer to determine who
has priority
and i should also mention they wanted us
to do the drive-through
testing as well and that was later on
but initially
and even still today the emergency room
has priority
uh our transplant patients and our
pre-surgical patients
so it may differ in other institutions
but that is what has worked for us
but i have to say that the total
laboratory automation
was a significant factor in our
utilizing
uh not only processors but some of our
techs
to train and supplement the current
molecular
diagnostic staff and they were free to
train on these different platforms
and we basically have seamlessly for the
most part
been able to meet our tasks and meet the
volumes associated with cova testing
which for us has not let up yet so once
again it's one of those situations where
prior planning is really critical
so why total laboratory automation i've
listed here several entities that
explain or characterize
why you want to consider total
laboratory automation
i think the one thing that's driving it
is we're being told we're asked to do
more with less
we're in the era of rapid diagnostics
physicians know that
and they want the results as soon as
possible
and other factors that you could see
there supporting antimicrobial
stewardship as dr rodney humphries
mentioned
uh support infection control and screen
patients for hospital-acquired
infections
and at the same time provide rapid
testing for covet
and hundreds of tests per day
i can summarize this very quickly it's a
matter of survival not only for now
but in the future
so once again to continue on with total
laboratory
automation our experience has been that
it has allowed us to reduce
the time required to inoculate media by
up to 70
at the same time it increases efficiency
and productivity
and when you combine that with mass
spectrometry it
allows you to optimize your workflow it
does
reduce cost which i'll show you later
and
obviously time to pathogen
identification
it does support our goal of becoming a
24
7 dedicated microbiology staff we did
get approval
for creating a 24 7 dedicated
microbiology staff but covetous
has put some hindrance in that at the
point we are reading plates
and doing susceptibility testing up
until about 11 o'clock then after that
we have to wait till the next morning
but we're on track to do that
and as i like to say to my
administrators
microbiology is not designed to make
money
rather it's to save money for the
institution
and thus i think that microbiology and
the entire laboratory for that
matter should be considered as a center
of savings
and not a cost center
so the advantages of automation as many
of you can already appreciate is it
standardizes
promotes uniformity and consistency it
does contribute
to a reduction in technical errors which
i will address
when we get into the experiences with
the
prototype that we'll talk about it
increases efficiency that's a term that
administrators like to use along with
increased productivity
and reduced labor costs and labor cost
is not intended to replace people
but to utilize more effectively your
staff
or other duties in either micro
bacteriology my mycology molecular and
so forth
so you don't necessarily have to add
ftes
but rather you utilize them more
efficiently
so as i said we've been a tloa
laboratory for the past three years that
automates specimen processing in the
system known as
the inoculate the culture plates are
automatically transported to smart
incubators
which are actually called redus and
digital imaging is is really an
advancement
in assessing and evaluating the cultures
and the reduction in time to reporting
currently our plates can be read as
early as 14 hours
following inoculation the big factor
contributing to that
is the fact that the incubators are
never open so the temperature remains
constant it's same-day id with maldi-tof
so we'll have that id out in less than
24 hours usually
antimicrobial susceptibility testing
still requires
overnight or 18 to 24 hours but actually
we're getting our results our final
results out for the most part
in less than 48 hours and of course
negative urine cultures can be
read eliminated and finalized
during that period of time the big thing
is the ergonomic benefits as well
the techs do not have to get up and down
to retrieve or
to add cultures to the incubators
and they are simply working at a
workstation
doing everything on digital analysis
and the only labor comes in is when the
culture is referred to what we call the
picker bench
and the technologist at the picker bench
calls or tells the incubator to send the
plates to them
they already know versus the
the prior communication with the tech
that read the plate what colonies to
pick
and set up for multi-top as well as
susceptibility testing
so the study objectives in this clinical
trial that we were fortunate
to participate in was actually to
compare the performance
in a clinical setting in an everyday
laboratory
of this fully automated ruo prototype
the bd keystroke system and i'll show
you a photo of here in a minute
with full automation of identification
and susceptibility testing
we want to compare it to the current
method or what we call manual methods
and involving the systems now i will
tell you
that in the automated segment of the
study the finish the bd phoenix
m50 was in addition to the laboratory
as a separate stand-alone instrument and
in the automated system and i'll
describe for a moment
there's also a phoenix apparatus there
we obviously wanted to investigate the
agreement between the two systems
automated versus manual and then assess
the potential of this automated system
which we refer to as the prototype to
enhance the operational
and clinical performance because of the
value
of the automated colony picker the
preparation of the bacterial suspension
the spotting of the bd broker multi-top
the bio type or target plate rather
and inoculating the phoenix m50
susceptibility panel
this is a photo of the prototype and i
will tell you right up front this is not
available for sale
in the u.s it's still a large part of it
it's still
in development i would ask or recommend
that you talk to your vd rep for any
update on that but this prototype that
was
placed in our laboratory this is not a
guarantee that this is what the final
project is going to look like
but essentially on the left side here in
the area called the identifia
there is a broker on board broker
the colony picker is is associated with
the instrument as well
and on the right side is the automated
susceptibility testing module
and as a result of that uh you have both
uh in one uh system here this is the
broker that sits in our laboratory and
i'm sure in many of yours
once again we had the end the or the m50
phoenix associated with the study as
well
because that was part of the manual
aspect of the study
but the specific performance criteria
that we were interested in where the
percent of isolates can be identified
the average identification score
compared to manual identification
it wasn't a major part of the study but
we did
want to know the estimated labor
costs and uh we will present that in a
few moments
and uh some of the other performance
criteria that we evaluated
and i should mention that this paper
along with our colleagues in switzerland
are both published
we published our paper in clinical
microbiology and infection
in july of last year and our colleagues
in switzerland
uh published theirs in october of last
year
two totally independent studies
both of which are published so the
methods
briefly were the isolates were
selected by technologists from our
specimens
that were eligible in his or her mind
clinically relevant for further id and
ast
and then that was followed by three to
nine
well isolated colonies selected manually
for the current manual preparation so
the current manual
preparation was select the colonies
spot them on them manually spot them on
the
multi-top prepare a standardized
suspension
and inoculate the phoenix system
these colonies are also marked in the
digital images
for automation so the technologists that
were associated with the automated port
knew what colonies three to nine were to
be picked
uh from the digital images and as i said
the onboard picking system
actually did the picking or the
acquisition of those colonies
and uh it prepared it for both id and
susceptibility testing
once again with the onboard maldi and on
board phoenix
i should point out that in the manual
system there was actually
two separate inocula that were used one
for the id
one for the ast which as everyone knows
could be a variable
but it was a single inoculum in the
automated segment of the study
ids were repeated manually from a
subculture of well-isolated colonies if
the maldi scores
were less than 1.7 or the automated
system
and the manual system yield discrepant
ids
so asts were repeated that there were
major categorical differences
of mics and they had to differ by more
than one doubling dilution
if discordant results were observed uh
or recurred in the repeated tests these
isolates were then referred to testing
by the microscan which is our primary
system
for susceptibility testing in our
laboratory
and ultimately the microscan was the
referee
for discordant results
so we initially
you can see here we had 523
total isolates evaluated representing a
variety of clinical specimens
and as a result of that we thought we
had a good representation
of the distribution of isolates a large
number
of course gram-negative i point out that
enterobacter rogenese as you know is now
klebsiella
erogenese and as a result of that at
that time
the broker the database had not updated
the clutciola
so that's why i wanted to point out the
intro factor
and these are mostly the grand positive
organisms
we had three of the 520 that simply
did not give peaks on the maldi in both
the automated
as well as the
manual system so 520 but overall the
data will represent
523. so if you look at the multiscores
once again less than or equal to 1.7
in the above section here this is the
initial testing
of these 523 isolates and
you can see that 86.9 percent scored
greater than two
2.1 percent as you can see
scored between 1.7 and 1.99
and what this actually
indicates is that
before repeat testing there was an 89
and 92.9 percent
respectively automated and manual
that had scores uh
in the range that you see here once we
repeated
those i think there were 57 israelites
or something like that
we we increased that to 96 or i'm sorry
97 percent
and the manual system was 98 so there
was very very
close agreement there between the two
major problems in spotting were through
the manual method
we had more errors with that and as you
know spotting a multi
as far as i'm concerned is at heart and
it takes skilled technologists to
effectively spot the moldy template
there was also occasional difficulty in
testing
mucoid isolates pinpoint or small
colonies
and some streptococcus isolates gave us
problems
there was also as i indicated earlier
occasional incidents
where peaks were absent and uh
this occurred on both automated and
manual
and then we we attributed the scores
below 1.7
to be to result of low turbidity
or low biomass and note that the bd
keystroke identifier a
will always regardless of the density
process for maldi and so forth
even if the mcfarland standard is below
0.2
[Music]
so the benefits of automated
identification we found it was rapid
if it's accurate reliable we'll show you
that was cost effective
it did promote increased productivity
and efficiency
and really the nicer highlight is
standardization and uniformity and we
also notice very minimal
maintenance which is something you need
to take into consideration
of the ast results we had 7512 evaluable
drug bug organ tests and as a result of
that
the overall percentage of accuracy was
98.7 percent
we also noticed that over 1600 of these
combinations both methods yielded
on-scale results that is
a definitive mic i'll say a little more
about the costs here in a moment
and it's very significant
overall there was a central agreement
between the two
systems of 98.7 which is very good
and categorical agreement almost 98
once again very good and there were very
few
uh major categorical discrepancies
table 7 refers to that table which is in
the publication
so if we look at our labor costs and
it's strictly labor
not including reagents and so forth we
found that in the manual versus the
automated system
it was 83 cents to identify
one isolate and for 16
isolates which was the number of isis we
tested at one time it's 13.20
the isolates the same process for the
automated that cost us five
cents for both id and susceptibility
testing so the total labor
saved is quite significant as you can
see here and then the susceptibility
testing uh we saved for 100 isolates
this amount of money if we take this and
put it on a monthly basis and estimate
our workload of 1000 isolates per month
uh we could then see a savings of over
twenty three hundred dollars
in the first in a month or annually a
savings of twenty eight
thousand two hundred and sixty six
dollars and that's significant
information
that you need to provide to the
administrators
so the benefit is reduced hands-on time
no question about that reduces labor
does not replace people improved
efficiency
once again increased productivity
standardization
really eliminates technical errors that
can occur
with manual processing i mentioned a
little bit about improved ergonomics
it did potentially if we were to use it
would optimize
our workflow and also promotes greater
chemical and biological safety
so in summary there was excellent
agreement
and analytical performance of this fully
automated system
significant advantages as i already have
mentioned such as efficiency
standardization reproducibility and
the addition of this system to the
current tla
in the keister system
uh is going to be a tremendous asset
matter of fact we have it
in our budget when the system becomes
available
so with our current tla we were better
able
to use our personnel resources for covet
testing
and once again it frees people up to do
other things
and and and the controversy that was
initiated
at the beginning i think we can say at
this point
total or full laboratory automotion
automation has become a reality and very
excited about that
and i hope sometime we can have a full
automation
concept for testing all these covet
specimens
i'm sure like you uh we are tired
uh morale is a little low with all the
cova testing coming in
and rather than four platforms i'd like
to see one platform
that can handle it all very similar to
the lab automation that we just
described
so with that i want to acknowledge my
team
and and they worked very hard on this
for about almost five months
and i should recognize dr ken thompson
who handled all the susceptibility
aspects of the study including the
management of the data
so with that i will thank you and turn
it back over to our moderator
and thank you dr snyder and dr humphries
for that informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have any questions you want to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
so let's get started it looks like we
already have some great
questions coming in from our audience
members
our first question what additional
benefits
were observed from the overall tla
system the automated um streaking and
incubation
one of the primary benefits that were
the result
of uh standardized streaking of plates
as opposed to manual streaking of plates
you know no one individual streaks the
same way
but with the automation the the plates
are
standard and reproducible on every plate
the other is the automated
inoculation of the specimens uh once the
specimen is identified in the kystra it
talks to the inoculate
it sends automatically sends the
appropriate media
to the inoculation station
and each uh nocus consists of 10
microliters
followed by the use of a magnetic bead
that streaks the plates
once they're streaked they are
taken automatically to the smart
incubators
the standardization and uniformity
thank you so much now is the
stenotrophomonas
considered a gram positive organism
now that the speaker had had included it
with gram-positive
organism group
well it's gram-negative but that could
have been a
misplacement of the organism but still
knows the gram-negative rod
thank you very much and i want to thank
our audience for these great questions
coming in we have time for a few more
what
aspect of automation has been the most
impactful
to your lab
i would have to say from our perspective
is better utilization
and more efficient utilization of
personnel
we don't have we did not have to
increase fdes
and uh the only thing we've added and
primarily because of covet
were lab assistants to processing but
once they put the
uh president on the inocula
they're free to do something else and
free to do something else translates
into our
world as answering the phones that bring
all day
thank you so much dr schneider and are
you seeing a greater
appetite for administrators to invest
in technologies to automate routine
processes
i will say somewhat uh
i don't know how it is in the other
participants laboratories
but all our administrators are focused
on is coveted they don't want to talk
about anything else
but if i can tie whatever it is to covet
then i get their attention
we wanted another instrument and i said
this would really
be a great value in our support of covet
testing
and i had it within a month so it
depends upon how you present it
and the value added and in this case the
value added
was improving covet testing and reducing
turnaround time
thank you so much and we have one more
question and this one's for dr humphries
can you can you tell us how covid
will impact the microbiology operations
long-term dr humphries yeah
that's a great question um i think you
know as dr snyder kind of went through
we're learning a lot about our workflow
and how to make our processes as
efficient as possible um this can be
really tricky to manage um but you know
the the end of the day especially going
through this pandemic
if something isn't value-added it needs
to be cut
so that's one big thing and i think that
we will see a movement towards more
automation
and hopefully just you know general
increased awareness of the value that
the lab provides
as well as um in particular it's a
clinical microbiology infectious
diseases labs
thank you so much dr humphries and dr
schneider we have actually one more
um question for you and we have time for
that question
could you affirm that having the entire
diagnostic processing
automated you are allowed now to do
better advisory tasks
in the anti-microbial stewardship
demands
no question about it but it also gives
the opportunity to
build up your other sections such as the
mycobacteria
the mycology and other areas including
molecular diagnostics we're moving
forward
in our molecular diagnostics for
bringing on new tests
with this automation that's going to
make it
much simpler or easier because we'll
have more time to focus on it
i want to thank you so much both of you
for your time today would you like to
provide
some closing remarks for our audience
i'll start with you dr humphreys
um you know i think that the biggest
thing is that
lab testing is important we've seen that
we've seen how important it is and
i think you know we we all in the
clinical labs
do our best to have the best quality
results and at the end of the day i hope
we all
can appreciate how much impact that can
have on patient care and management
you know during a pandemic but also
outside the pandemic
absolutely and dr schneider i think the
last year
has brought the laboratory to the
highest level visibility than ever
before
that is the administrators and
the management really don't understand
who microbiology or the laboratory as a
whole is
and what they do they look at it as a
necessary
evil but i cannot tell you how much
attention the laboratory has
gotten from the higher ups if you will
and saying gee you guys really do
contribute significantly
to patient care when we look at them and
say we that's all we do
and as a result of that i would
encourage everybody to consider
reading the recent general clinical
microbiology
with dr lanaz samuel's paper in there
regarding
the need for dedicated microbiology
leadership
in the clinical microbiology laboratory
i am very proud of what i do i know dr
humphries is as well
but i'm most proud of our technologists
who
are really the ones that make us
successful because they're committed to
what they do
so with that i will turn it back to you
well dr schneider and dr humphries thank
you again for your time today and for
your important research
and before we go i want to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions that we do not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and
i'd also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor bd for underwriting
today's educational webcast you can view
this webinar on demand
and lab routes will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
that's all for now until next time take
care and
stay safe bye bye everyone
you